bonjour et bienvenue dans europe hebdo
nous sommes ici dans ce qu'on appelle la
rue du parlement européen
ici à bruxelles cette semaine gros plan
sur l'hôtellerie en europe avec des
étoiles qui n'ont pas la même valeur
d'un pays à l'autre
reportage à chypre il est tout de suite
une question l'euro est il enfin sauvée
onze heures de tractations et au petit
matin un accord historique pour sauver
la zone euro
un effort massif le plan de secours
adopté pourra aller jusqu'à 750
milliards d'euros grâce à un mécanisme à
trois étages
la commission européenne pourra prêter
jusqu'à 60 milliards d'euros aux pays en
difficulté une somme que bruxelles
empruntera sur les marchés en échange de
la garantie apportée par le budget
communautaire
les états membres apportent de leur côté
une garantie de 440 milliards d'euros
elle passera par un fonds européen qui
pourra lever des fonds sur les marchés
en cas de besoin enfin le fmi mais sa
force de frappe à disposition des
européens avec une contribution évaluée
à 250 milliards d'euros
autre effort inédit la banque centrale
européenne se donne la possibilité de
racheter des titres de la dette publique
des pays de la zone euro en échange de
l'aide promise
les états s'engagent à accélérer le
redressement de leurs comptes publics
il faut attaquer les problèmes à la
racine est vraiment combattre les causes
des difficultés et c'est pour cela qu'il
est très important de consolider le
budget de tous les pays de la zone euro
un appel à la discipline budgétaire
devenue prioritaire en europe la
chancelière allemande a elle même
renoncé à baisser les impôts l'une de
ses grandes promesses de campagne
en france les dépenses publiques seront
gelés pendant trois ans des politiques
de rigueur en perspective qui pourrait
coûter cher à l'heure où l'économie
européenne montre des signes timides de
reprise
alors là nous sommes avec sylvie goulard
bonjour vous êtes donc députée
européenne vous êtes membre du groupe
des démocrates et des libéraux et vous
êtes une fine connaisseuse des affaires
économiques au niveau européen est ce
que le plan de sauvetage de l'euro qu'on
vient de voir est ce que ce plan selon
vous est ce suffisant
il est suffisant enfin j'espère en tout
cas ce jour pour enrayer la panique sur
les marchés à laquelle nous avons
assisté ces derniers jours ça c'est un
élément important dans la crise en
revanche il faudra le compléter comme le
reportage l'a montré par des mesures qui
règle la cause de ces difficultés les
marchés s'attaquent sa veste comme les
requins et s'attaque à un baigneur
blessés d'abord il il est soigné
non justement on a on a paré au plus
pressé mon avis on a mis sur la plage et
on va essayer mais il faut que quand ils
retournent se baigner il soit vraiment
en bonne santé donc ça c'est la chose la
plus important c'est ce qu'a dit madame
merkel je crois que tous les états
membres de la zone euro doivent être
sérieux avec leurs engagements de fond
de réformes économiques alors on a vu
que en période de crise on savait
souvent prendre les bonnes décisions
tout cas là l'europe l'a prouvé mais
ensuite une fois que la crise aiguë est
passé c'est plus difficile justement de
faire des réformes
vous vous êtes confiante vous pensez que
les réformes vont se faire en europe
d'abord je crois que c'est une
caractéristique des êtres humains il
faut arrêter de dire que c'est seulement
en europe il est très fréquent que
malheureusement les gens réagissent
quand ils sont le dos au mur on peut le
regretter mais l'essentiel c'est que le
virage a été pris
deuxièmement j'espère que les médias
vont nous aider qu'on va parler d'europe
à froid qu'on va arriver à faire de la
pédagogie entre les moments les plus
chauds et que du coup les opinions
publiques comprendront des mesures à
faire parce que par exemple la
commission européenne fait un certain
nombre de propositions en particulier le
fait que souhaiterait que les états lui
fasse parvenir ses budgets avant qu'il
soit adopté par
par par les parlements nationaux et ce
qu'on pensait que ça c'est possible le
faire ce qui est certain c'est qu'une
monnaie commune
ça veut dire un destin politique commun
est beaucoup plus de décisions à prendre
en commun ça veut pas dire que la
commission doit se mêler de tout mais il
faut qu'il y ait une vérification
précise que chacun prend sa part et le
travail à faire dans chacun des états
membres de la zone euro peut être
d'ailleurs assez différent donc s'agit
pas de tout communautariser mais d'avoir
une vraie surveillance dans le respect
bien sûr des prérogatives des parlements
nationaux
et puis le parlement européen fera aussi
sa part par exemple cette semaine nous
avons adopté tout un ensemble de règles
en commission économique et monétaire
s'est pas encore la plénière sur la
supervision des marchés financiers
est ce que vous pensez par exemple que
la france peut accepter que son budget
parce que budget c'est quand même un peu
le coeur du réacteur d'un état que son
budget passe d'abord ici à bruxelles
avant d'être voté par le parlement
si c'est un dialogue je vois pas où est
le problème et je rappellerai aux
français que s'il n'y avait pas l'euro
le franc en ce moment aurait été
gravement d'évaluer la situation de
notre pays ne nous permet pas de
continuer à vivre au dessus de nos
moyens nous avons pris un engagement
lorsque les allemands s'ils font un peu
expliqué pourquoi les allemands ont tant
tardé à donner leur accord
nous vivions autrefois dans une sorte de
zone marque de fait le franc était
accrochée aux marques et lorsqu'il y
avait des problèmes en france est une
vertu moins grande qu'en allemagne nous
étions obligées de dévaluer ça nous ne
le faisons plus nous avons bénéficié en
2008 2009 de la protection de l'euro en
contrepartie la france doit être
sérieuse ensuite il faut voir quelles
sont les modalités j'ai dit faut
respecter les prérogatives des
parlements nationaux me faut aussi
qu'ils parlent qu'ils prennent leur part
d'europe sur la seule ment sur le plan
des déficits on a vu par exemple que les
marchés financiers c'est aussi pour ça
qu'ils avaient beaucoup décroché il
était tout à fait sensible au fait qu'il
n'y avait pas l'annoncent forte sur les
déficits des états là l'espagne annonce
un nouveau plan d'austérité une baisse
des salaires des fonctionnaires par
exemple est-ce que c'est suffisant ou
est-ce qu'il faut que ce soit tous les
pays européens qui annoncent des plans
d'austérité jamais mais tous les pays
européens dans le même sac
il ya des états membres eux mêmes de la
zone euro vous avez des états manquent
comme l'autriche la finlande les pays
bas l'allemand
un qui dépasse à peine les seuls qui
sont fixées par le pacte de stabilité
ces pays ont fait des réformes et
parfois des réformes douloureuses des
réformes difficiles
notre pays est à peu près à 8% de
déficit alors que la règle est à 3 il y
à des mesures à prendre et je dois dire
que si vous regardez le rapport qui
avait été fait en 2005 par michel
pébereau à la demande du ministre de
l'économie à l'époque c'était un rapport
extrêmement alarmiste donc ce constat il
a été fait en france et pas la
commission
françois fillon avait dit je suis à la
tête d'un etat en faillite déjà et il a
raison il donc il faut que les français
se ressaisissent et je crois qu'il faut
pas seulement dire que c'est une
cuillère d'huile de foie de morue nos
emplois dépendent de de cet
assainissement nos emplois dépendent de
la lutte contre des niches fiscales
absolument insensé qui ont été créées
qui coûte très cher au budget de l'état
sylvie goulard alors on va continuer
l'actualité européenne cette semaine est
extrêmement riche et je vous propose
donc ce tour d'europe
regardez
coup dur pour angela merkel qui a subi
un revers électoral lors du scrutin
organisé en rhénanie du nord westphalie
sa coalition alliance des chrétiens
démocrates et des libéraux a perdu cette
région la plus peuplée et la plus
puissante du pays conséquence la
chancelière allemande a perdu la
majorité au bundesrat la chambre haute
du parlement allemand qui représente les
16 länder
elle devra composer avec l'opposition
sociale-démocrate sa majesté la reine
m'a demandé de former un nouveau
gouvernement
et j'ai accepté à 43 ans david cameron
devient le plus jeune premier ministre
du royaume uni depuis 200 ans
le chef des conservateurs est
officiellement installé au thème
d'herning street
il dirigera un gouvernement de coalition
avec les libéraux démocrates de nick
clegg qui devient vice premier ministre
leur priorité la réduction du déficit et
des mesures pour assurer la reprise
économique
en belgique on votera le 13 juin
prochain les élections anticipées qui
font suite à la démission du
gouvernement d'yves leterme tombé sur le
dossier les querelles linguistiques
entre flamands et francophones dans la
banlieue de bruxelles
des élections cruciales pour le pays qui
espère avoir un premier ministre en
exercice le 1er juillet prochain
quand la belgique prendra la présidence
tournante de l'union européenne
tout le monde en pince passer de
l'europe s'est mortellement
et puis l'europe en fête à l'occasion du
60e anniversaire de la déclaration
schuman ambiance ludique et
commémorative 9 mai 1950 le ministre
français des affaires étrangères
prononce un discours historique dans le
salon de l'horloge du quai d'orsay
ils appellent la france et l'allemagne à
mettre en commun leur production de
charbon et d'acier première pierre de
l'intégration européenne
alors on voit que ça bouge beaucoup sur
les scènes politiques nationales en
europe
david cameron est donc le nouveau
premier ministre au royaume uni est-ce
que sur le plan européen le fait que le
royaume uni est un premier ministre
conservateur ça va changer la donne bien
sûr enfin c'est une nouvelle équipe on
peut pas dire que les conservateurs sont
exactement sur la même ligne que les
l'album il ya deux phénomènes
intéressant le premier c'est que la
première fois qu' un gouvernement de
coalition enfin depuis des décennies au
royaume-uni et que c'est quand même un
attelage assez bizarre puisque vous avez
les conservateurs qui sont la famille de
madame thatcher et les libéraux
démocrates qui sont des fédéralistes
européens
donc ça c'est aussi quand même assez
amusant que en dépit de ce soi-disant
boulet dans un pays qui est anti
européen on est cette conjonction la
joie va avancer au contraire ils vont se
neutraliser
c'est difficile à dire à ce stade c'est
un vrai changement et je crois que c'est
aussi le signe que ce pays d'une
certaine manière se normalise c'est
assez drôle de voir comme ils étaient
perdus à l'idée de faire dans le fond ce
que font les allemands ce que font des
tas d'autres pays d'europe c'est à dire
gouverner les uns avec les autres
alors un autre pays où il ya une
coalition c'est en allemagne est ce que
madame merkel a perdu son élection
régionale du week-end dernier sur la
grèce il ya des raisons plus profondes
c'est un lot qui est traditionnellement
à gauche ça avait été plutôt étonnant
qu'en 2005 accéder ou gagnent les
élections on entendra une estrade
vieille terre charbonnières et ouvriers
donc effectivement c'est un changement
mais en allemagne savez l'esprit de
coalition est très présent et on ne sait
même pas d'ailleurs si la coalition va
être une coalition de gauche avec les
verts et les socialistes ou une
coalition dans laquelle il pourrait y
avoir ceux qui au niveau fédéral
gouverne avec madame merkel est ce que
vous faites partie de ceux qui pensent
ils sont quand même nombreux en europe
que angela merkel a mené à la situation
de crise on revient un peu à notre sujet
précédent mais la situation de crise sur
l'euro est ce que c est la responsable
absolument pas alors là là dessus je
vais très franche je pense que par
exemple les français ont une part énorme
de responsables
tout simplement parce que pour que ça
marche il faut de la solidarité peut
être que là en allemagne a eu un petit
retard encore que la cour
constitutionnelle avait mis l'allemagne
dans une situation extrêmement difficile
il faut le rappeler mais surtout lorsque
nous avons fait l'euro nous avions dit
aux allemands que nous ferions tout pour
que la monnaie soit préservée et pour
que les accords soient respectées mais
là en quelques en quelques mots pourquoi
les français sont ils responsables de la
crise de ces dernières semaines parce
que le ne pas seulement les français
mais en partie des français étant le
premier partenaire de l'allemagne
vous avez tout un phénomène en allemagne
qui est de doute sur la construction
européenne parce que les partenaires de
l'allemagne n'ont pas respecté leur
parole pour ce qui est des conditions
dans lesquelles nous avons fait la
monnaie unique
donc il ya une part de responsabilité en
allemagne dans le rythme notamment de la
réponse à chaud il y avait une crise il
fallait répondre plus vite c'est vrai
mais si on a eu la crise c'est aussi
parce que les autres partenaires de
l'allemagne n'ont pas été servis merci
beaucoup
sylvie goulard alors vous êtes députée
européenne vous voyagez beaucoup et vous
êtes sûrement rendu compte que quand
vous allez dans des hôtels en europe et
bien les étoiles de ses hôtels n'ont
rien à voir
d'un pays à l'autre et bien c'est le
sujet du débat avec kathia gilder oui
nous sommes allés à chypre l'une des
grandes destinations touristiques en
europe très prisée des britanniques
l'île compte de très nombreux hôtels le
problème c'est que les normes hôtelières
ne sont pas forcément les mêmes qu'en
france ou en allemagne
reportage de julien loko rec
chypre son soleil ses plages ses étoiles
de mer et ses étoiles hôtelières dans
les années 80 les complexes hôteliers
des trois quatre cinq étoiles en floride
au sud de l'île
car le nord lui est annexé par la
turquie depuis 1974 et peu ouvert au
tourisme
nous sommes à ayia napa sur la partie
européenne une destination très prisée
par les anglais et depuis peu par les
tours opérateurs français raphaël
richard et journalistes il est
accompagné de patrice son photographe
son métier tester des hôtels shalev il
travaille pour easyvoyage un site
internet qui évalue les hôtels dans le
monde
lancée en 2001 l'entreprise est devenue
le leader des comparateurs d'hôtels en
france nous sommes à l'hôtel asterias
beach un 4 étoiles pour raphaël en
france il n'aurait obtenu que deux
étoiles
c'est un indicateur mais ça représente
vraiment pas grand chose en fait les les
normes hôtelières les classement
hôtelier par étoiles sont un peu
sont différents d'un pays à l'autre et
est en fait personne ne s'y retrouve
vraiment quoi c'est pas facile
chypre l'un des plus petits pays de
l'union européenne entré en 2004 la
petite soeur de la grèce a beaucoup
souffert de la crise le nombre de
touristes est en baisse de 10% par
rapport à 2009
alors pour le directeur de l'hôtel vient
suivre les normes européennes c'est
rester compétitif je pense que le
gouvernement suit l'europe quoi que
l'europe dise surtout pour chypre un
petit pays mais un membre important de
l'europe
nous le faisons je pense que c'est très
logique que l'europe demande beaucoup
aux hôtels parce que c'est un marché
très concurrentiel et à la fin c'est le
meilleur qui survivra en face l'hôtel le
dôme lui aussi sur la liste de raphaël
visite avec son directeur s'est lui
aussi un hôtel quatre étoiles mais il
n'a pourtant rien à voir avec le premier
ce qui est bien lancée en 2006 soit
morte et cissé mexès ou rénovation
totale en 2006 donc ça se voit sur ces
voix là parce que le fait que la
peinture soit fraîche ça va pas rentrer
dans une classification hôtelière lambda
donc sans le savoir quand vous n'en
loire sur l'île c'est la mairie qui
délivre les fameuses étoiles et le
directeur de cet hôtel nous assure être
contrôlés régulièrement les quatre
étoiles sont contrôlés par la mairie par
l'office du tourisme de chypre
il y à une réglementation particulière
que vous devez appliquer pour les salles
de bains la salle de conférence le
restaurant et la qualité du service et
nous suivons les règles mais elle change
en réalité les contrôles sont très rares
et ne prennent en compte que des normes
d'équipement est pas la qualité de
l'accueil et du service
c'est pour cela qu'ils y voyage a mis en
place sa propre grille d'évaluation les
infrastructures d'abord donc c'est le
petit cheney
généralités sur sur le bâtiment lui-même
plus tôt ensuite il ya une partie
vraiment pour les chambres donc
particulièrement sur les chambres avec
l'équipement la sonorisation la lumière
la superficie il a vu enfin tous les
éléments de la chambre classique et puis
après on arrive vraiment partis qui sont
un peu plus propre à easy voyage ça veut
dire que aussi pour les hôtels clubs
on note aussi l'animation le but c'est
pas forcément de dire juste c'est bien
c'est pas bien ce site dire ben voilà
vous avez envie de tranquillité aller
plutôt vers cet hôtel là vous avez envie
d'animation vous avez envie d'un hôtel
proche des lieux festifs allait plutôt à
cet hôtel la voilà vous avez des enfants
et l hôtel est plus adapté pour les
gueux famille de l'opt elle est plus
adapté pour point couple en lune de miel
ou enfin voilà des étoiles qui sentit
plus ou moins en fonction des pays mais
à chypre les palaces sont aussi trois à
quatre fois moins chère en france au
prix de deux breaks feu autre
particularité de lille les hôtels sans
étoiles sont classés par lettres a b et
c
rien à voir avec le système français et
encore moins avec ceux des autres pays
européens
voilà on quitte le soleil de shit retour
à bruxelles au parlement européen deux
députés français sont avec nous gilles
pargneaux bonjour vous êtes députés du
groupe socialiste et démocrate en face
de vous votre collègue robert rochefort
bonjour député de vice président du
moden êtes-vous sujet ici à l'alliance
des démocrates et des libéraux européens
alors robert rochefort on le voit dans
ce reportage
finalement les règles sont un petit peu
flou on avait vu que c'était la mairie
qui pouvait attribuer les hôtels
hôtelière est ce qu'il n'ya pas selon
vous besoin de clarifications dans ce
secteur la tonalité du reportage me
frappe parce que j'ai l'impression que
quand l'europe est très présente on la
trappe de vouloir tout réglementer et
lorsque par hasard elle n'est pas
extrêmement présente on vient en disant
il faudrait mettre de l'ordre là dedans
écoutez moi je vais vous donner mon
sentiment très rapidement je crois à la
fois qu'il faut essayer d'harmoniser
petit à petit nos règles et en même
temps il faut pas décidé depuis
bruxelles ou strasbourg
quelles doivent être les consignes et
fictive hôtel par hôtel sur l'ensemble
du territoire européen
vous avez d'ailleurs bien vu que on peut
pas tout réduire à des qualités
techniques
les gens qui aiment l'animation de
centre ville les gens qui aiment le
calme
ce sont des critères importants pour le
choix des consommateurs donc il faut
qu'ils aient des multiples choix un peu
plus d'ordre mais n'allons tout de même
pas vers une sorte de deux régiments des
hôtels aussi strictes que les corps
d'une armée
d'un pays où d'un autre c'est ce que
vous pensez aussi gilles pargneaux qu'il
faut laisser un peu de souplesse à ce
secteur
ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut plus
d'europe et est fixé des règles des
règles qui permettent de protéger le
consommateur
car finalement c'est surtout cela qui
doit dans notre préoccupation première
nous avons la chance grâce au traité de
lisbonne avec l'article 195 d'avoir
maintenant un cadre juridique qui permet
en matière de tourisme à l'europe de
pouvoir délibérer ce qui n'était pas le
cas et six mois auparavant
dans le cadre de des traités précédents
de nice ou d'amsterdam
nous avions eu et c'est donc de
recommandations de résolution la
dernière c'était un projet initiative un
collègue costa italiens qui avaient un
fait adopter le ton cou qui avait fait
adopter ce rapport le 22 9 novembre 2007
la maintenant nous pouvons avec la
commission européenne
légiférer et faire en sorte qu'il y ait
des règles
or et on le voit avec ce reportage il
faut effectivement des règles permettant
ainsi aux consommateurs qui de plus en
plus en matière de tourisme en europe
accomplir ses réservations par internet
donc il faut non seulement qu'il y ait
des règles via ses réservations qui de
plus en plus se font par internet et
ensuite bien évidemment fait en sorte
que les arbitres que nous sommes l'union
européenne puis se faire en sorte que
tout le monde joue finalement sur le
même terrain franchement vous qui
défendez le consommateur vous admettez
que c'est un service à lui rendu père
m'a dit certes il ya deux sujets assez
différent rien un sujet qui concerne la
sécurité et la de ce point de vue
d'ailleurs l'europe a déjà fait des
choses les questions de normes incendie
de protection des voeux ça c'est très
bien si il ya également quelque chose
qui concerne l'accès aux personnes à
mobilité réduite pour lequel je crois
qu'il faut qu'il y ait une
standardisation et une protection très
grande du consommateur et puis à côté il
ya la question de la qualité comment
dire je dirais plus
subjective et moi je crois que le
consommateur aujourd'hui a besoin qu' il
y ait une diversité des propositions qui
sont faites et puis j'ai une petite
inquiétude quand même c'est qu'il ne
faudrait pas que avec comment dire trop
de règles comment dire imposer au niveau
de l'europe
on tue toute l'hôtellerie indépendante
qui existe dans toutes les villes de
taille moyenne
nous savons bien au cours des années
passées qui a eu si je prends l'exemple
de la france il ya à peu près autant de
chambres d'hôtels en france je crois que
l'ordre de 600 milles qui avait quelques
années mais il ya des milliers
d'établissements qui ont disparu
l'établissement de petite taille alors
il faut à la fois que cet établissement
puisse se moderniser que pour le
consommateur il ya une grande sécurité
mais qu'en même temps on garde une
diversité hôtelière savez si l'europe
est la première destination touristique
du monde c'est pas uniquement
il faut pas uniquement travailler ces
grands bâtiments standardisé avec des
chaînes commerciales
comment dire que l'on connaît plus ou
moins bien il ya aussi des lobbys aussi
peut-être et des agences de voyages qui
prennent le relais justement parce qu'il
n'y a pas deux sur les grandes chaînes
de déréglementation bien sûr non mais je
veux simplement vous dire
entendons nous bien parce que je pense
qu'on est d'accord oui de la
réglementation oui de la réglementation
sur les questions comment dire je vais
dire de prestations minimales par
exemple moi je pense qu'effectivement il
faut qu'il y ait un socle minimal en
dessous duquel on puisse pas faire
profession d'hôtellerie vous savez
d'ailleurs qu'en france la sensibilité
était venu avec les les incendies
parisien d'hôtel qui finalement n'était
pas des hôtels touristes y aillent oui
bon on n'est pas en désaccord mais en
même temps je pense qu'il est nécessaire
que cette industrie européenne qui
représente plus de 10 millions d'emplois
c'est 2 me
nom d'entreprise qui travaillent plus ou
moins dans le cadre de ce développement
donc nous avons aujourd'hui la chance de
pouvoir faire en sorte d'avoir par cette
politique européenne
un développement de malades souffrent
c'est être faux pas là dessus mais il
faut faire en sorte que à partir du
moment où nous sommes pour ce
développement qui est des règles
nouvelles qu'ils soient fixés je crois
aussi un deuxième exemple on a vu dans
ce reportage
des piscines la sécurisation notamment
par rapport aux enfants est importante
en matière de piscines hors dons à des
règles différentes ici en belgique ou en
france conçoit donc le hachis alors
gilles pargneaux c'est la tradition dans
cette émission on vous pose une question
en direct écouter les doléances de ce
directeur d'hôtel à chypre la seule
question que j'ai envie de poser ses
caisses que député européen vous
pourriez faire pour faciliter le
tourisme en europe
est ce que par exemple on ne pourrait
pas baisser les taxes d'aéroport et le
prix des billets d'avion pour inciter
les gens voyager sur la guerre
on élargit notre débat au tourisme en
europe comment on comment se porte-t-il
et qu'est ce que vous répondez à ce
monsieur précisément c'est je pense pas
que la solution soit uniquement faire en
sorte qu'il y ait des voyages low cost
partout en europe pour développer le
tourisme non il faut une qualité de
l'offre touristique qui soit supérieur
l'europe doit encore et continuer à
devenir plus attractive vis-à-vis de
l'ensemble des européennes et européens
mais aussi vis-à-vis de l'ensemble de
celles et ceux qui viennent en europe du
monde entier non c'est là que nous avons
ici hâtive à prendre avec la commission
européenne pour légiférer et faire en
sorte que nous puissions par exemple
faire en sorte que le tourisme de
proximité
le tourisme social le tourisme l'éco
label là aussi nous devons faire en
sorte et ça a été dit dans ce rapport
d'initiative que j'abordais tout à
l'heure de notre collègue costa
permettent ainsi une attractivité plus
forte et faire en sorte que nous soyons
encore plus nombreux officiels très
concrètes
l'avenir du tourisme en europe si on
veut dynamique et ça crée encore plus
d'emplois se sont tous les gens du reste
du monde qui viennent d'amérique mais
aussi d'asie maintenant alors là par
contre je suis pour qu'il y ait une
initiative européenne avec une sorte de
labellisation je dirais pour cette
clientèle internationale pas forcément
d'ailleurs de type étoiles soirée des
labels mais pas pour l'ensemble du
tourisme pour faire en sorte qu
effectivement n'oublions jamais qu'il y
à des touristes qui viennent en europe
et qui viennent pas en france en
allemagne en italie passe quelques jours
en france quelques jours en espagne
quelques jours en italie et pour cela je
pense qu'il faudrait une sorte de
traçabilité une possibilité de dire vous
allez pouvoir en passant d'une ville à
un autre d'un pays un an
on avoir une qualité effectivement de
service mais ça ça concerne un segment
alors pour cela oui faisons des choses
mais peut-être pas pour l'ensemble pour
que la vieille rente continue à la
nature elle l'europe tonnes de gier
justement on va vous inviter à découvrir
toutes les richesses et le patrimoine de
cette belle europe puisque s'ouvre le 14
mai exactement la nuit européenne des
musées
elle n'est pas seulement française elle
est vraiment européenne c'est la
cinquième édition est donc vous pouvez
aller dans tous ces musées partout en
europe
regardez la bande annonce
la nuit des musées samedi 15 mai 2010
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission
d'europe et d'eau présente et depuis
bruxelles la semaine prochaine nous
serons à strasbourg bonne suite de
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires
aimé césaire figure emblématique de la
martinique et de la communauté noire
inventé le concept de la négritude la
négritude faire référence à des groupes
humains qui ont subi les pires violences
de l'histoire une personnalité
exceptionnelle à la dimension
internationale un humaniste engagé
contre le racisme
il n'est pas vrai que le racisme est
mort nous avons 12 clair qu'il sévisse
est parfois là où on le croyait terrassé
à jamais à l'occasion de l'anniversaire
de l'abolition de l'esclavagé
ce voyage poétique retrace la vie du
grand homme politique et de culture va
passer air un documentaire de sarah
maldoror samedi à 22 heures suivie d'un
débat animé par élise lucet
publicsenat.fr devient le portail de
l'information politique
dès à présent vous pouvez suivre
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
en temps réel converser réagissent et
participer à tous les contenus du site
est toujours la chaîne public sénat en
direct 24 heures sur 24 comme l'ensemble
de vos émissions en vod en accès gratuit
et libre
bienvenue dans paroles du monde à
l'occasion de la coupe du monde de
football qui commence le 11 juin
prochain le bureau international du
travail sort son carton rouge contre le
travail des enfants d'après le bit et
ils sont plus de 200 millions dans le
monde - 18 ans a exercé une activité
professionnelle la moitié risquent leur
vie
c'est le dossier de cette émission au
programme également une rencontre avec
une journaliste palestinienne de
nationalité israélienne
roulades j'aime real publie miral chez
oh éditions
on commence comme d'habitude par notre
tour du monde et télévisions étrangères
ça s'appelle écran d'ailleurs et s'est
préparé par paul bouffard
parade digne de l'ère soviétique à
moscou le président russe dmitri
medvedev fait la victoire des alliés sur
les nazis
dix mille soldats et des caméras
embarquées sur les chars et autres
avions de chasse mais derrière le défilé
grandiose une polémique les
nationalistes voit d'un mauvais oeil que
la bannière étoilée marche au pas pour
la première fois sur la place rouge
survêtement et voile dans un stade de
gaza city
des palestiniennes improvisent une
compétition d'athlétisme course saut en
longueur ces femmes font du sport en
plein territoire gouverné par le hamas
pourtant pour les islamistes au pouvoir
l'activité est contraire aux lois
divines
pas de députés à la chambre des communes
pour l'extrême droite anglaise échec aux
législatives mais dans la rue bob riley
démontre que les membres du british
national party sont des hommes de
terrain
en visite dans la banlieue de londres
une bagarre éclate
l'homme politique rouent de coups un
jeune d'origine asiatique
c'est le plus jeune premier ministre
britannique depuis près de deux siècles
david cameron a été nommé par la reine
après la démission du sortant gordon
brown le chef de file des conservateurs
met donc fin à 13 ans de règne
travailliste et fait entrer les
libéraux-démocrates au gouvernement le
nouveau locataire du 10 downing street
avaient remporté les élections
législatives du 6 mai dernier mais sans
majorité absolue
les philippins l'appel neu petit garçon
il est le fils de l'ancienne présidente
cory et du sénateur ni neu benigno
aquino est le nouveau président des
philippines dans un pays où près d'un
habitant sur trois vit avec moins d'un
dollar par jour il avait fait de la
lutte contre la corruption et contre la
pauvreté la priorité de sa campagne
à noter que les violences qui ont
accompagné les élections ont fait au
moins dix morts
ils se sont ouvert dans un climat de
scepticisme après 18 mois d'interruption
les pourparlers ont repris entre
israéliens et palestiniens mais il
s'agit de négociations indirectes par
l'intermédiaire de l'émissaire américain
george mitchell
et en attendant d'avoir un état et bien
les palestiniens disposent d'un embryon
d'armée une force spéciale formée par
les états unis à la frontière
cisjordanienne
un son rôle c'est de défendre l'autorité
palestinienne ces soldats sont des
soldats palestinien membre du 2e
bataillon spécial il s'entraîne en
situation ici à jéricho en cisjordanie
pour désamorcer un attentat suicide ou
neutraliser un sniper des heures et des
heures d'entraînement pour ses troupes
déployées en cisjordanie contre 2 cible
clairement identifiés et gangs criminels
et le hamas
ap les forces de sécurité nationales ces
unités ont été créés en 2005 sur une
initiative américaine
trois bataillons de 500 hommes chacun
financée par washington des palestiniens
soigneusement recruté en cisjordanie
pour éviter tout lien avec la
criminalité ou le terrorisme
l'objectif créer une armée loyale envers
l'état palestinien à venir en attendant
ces unités doivent protéger le fatah
contre une éventuelle prise de contrôle
d'une faction rivale en l'occurrence le
hamas reste que les israéliens occupent
toujours la cisjordanie
certains voient d'un mauvais oeil c'est
un mets nationale capable de prendre les
armes contre israël
d'autres lui reprochent de n'être que le
supplétif de l'occupation israélienne
seule la création ferme et définitive
d'un état palestinien pourrait mettre
fin aux soupçons c'est leur dernière
exigence avant de mettre fin à leur
mouvement en thaïlande les chemises
rouges demandent au vice premier
ministre de se rendre à la police
les manifestants estiment qu'il est à
l'origine des affrontements qui ont fait
25 morts et 800 blessés le 10 avril
dernier
et la crise qui dure depuis la mi mars
paralysent le centre de bangkok et
commence à peser sur l'économie
les opposants au régime ont déjà obtenu
du premier ministre l'organisation
d'élections anticipées le 14 novembre
prochain
il l'a choisi pour son excellence et son
intégrité désigné par barack obama
elena kagan est la troisième femme de la
cour suprême nommée un an après sonia
sotomayor elle a été la première femme à
occuper le poste de solliciteur général
qui défend la position du gouvernement
américain devant la cour suprême
brillante juriste progressiste elle
s'était également fait remarquer
lorsqu'elle était doyenne de harvard
elle avait bloqué l'accès au campus aux
recruteurs de l'armée pour protester
contre l'interdiction qui est faite qui
était faite aux homosexuels de s'enrôler
les souffrances viennent de l'intérieur
du péché qui existe dans l'église c'est
par ces mots que le pape est revenu sur
les scandales de pédophilie qui touche
l'église catholique lors d'un voyage de
quatre jours au portugal une visite dans
un pays ami illustré par cette photo
décrypté par mireille lemaresquier la
chef du service monde